if you control who gets a practice
profession you also get to control how
its practiced the licensure effort
that's an attempt to silence CrossFit on
the subject of nutrition and exercise
the state legislature that would adopt a
statewide licensure program for exercise
is composed of people who do not
understand anything about the squat a
federal government has designed this
food pyramid for the past three decades
almost everything the federal government
has told the public about eating a
healthy diet may have been wrong
when nutrition guidelines that were set
in the late 1970s it was primarily
politics when it comes to calories fat
is the enemy the Surgeon General told
Americans to avoid saturated fat and
prioritize grains and other
carbohydrates low fat products began
filling the aisles at grocery stores as
families tried to follow the
government's famous food pyramid at its
base our foods like breads and pastas
that should be eaten in greatest
quantity as obesity continued to climb
in America some dissenting scientists
and experts began to question the
consensus but the US government and
major health organizations were slow to
react only just now beginning to update
their recommendations and some fitness
professionals are afraid that what
happened to the field of nutrition is
about to happen to exercise all of these
government agencies all of our
universities they've all sat silent
through one of the worst declines in
health that modern world's ever seen
and the response is still is still
exactly wrong Greg Glassman is the
founder of CrossFit which is a corporate
donor to the nonprofit that publishes
reason CrossFit has disrupted the
personal fitness industry by taking a
radically different approach to both
nutrition and exercise in contrast to
much of the competition and against the
recommendations of many establishment
scientists CrossFit has always
emphasized high-intensity workout and a
low-carb diet the approach has been
wildly successful for CrossFit which
went from 13 gyms in 2005 to more than
13,000 across
world today but Glassman says the rise
to the top has entailed near constant
battle with the opposition and so we've
made some nice enemies out of a good
chunk of the food and beverage industry
and all of its clowns that do its
bidding
CrossFit's explosive growth was made
possible in no small part by the lack of
regulation in the fitness industry while
many states require licenses for
occupations as innocuous as trimming
trees tending bar braiding hair or even
arranging flowers personal trainers can
work without government oversight this
arrangement allows CrossFit to have its
own certification program that ignores
most of the conventional nutrition and
exercise advice emanating from
government and academic institutions but
over the past several years competing
credentialing organizations have joined
together to lobby for government
licensure of fitness trainers in several
states that's an attempt to silence
CrossFit on the subject of nutrition and
exercise the fight is occurring largely
behind the scenes at state legislatures
across the country where licensing laws
have been introduced on 26 separate
occasions
since 2005 but CrossFit supporters have
pushed back just as hard at times
showing up in person to speak out
against the bills the one place where
CrossFit lost the battle was Washington
DC which passed the nation's first
fitness trainer licensure law in 2014
though even that hasn't gone fully into
effect if you control who gets a
practice of profession you also get to
control how its practiced Russ green is
CrossFit's point man in the fight
against government licensure he says
that licensing could kill a program like
CrossFit are we going to be free to talk
to each other about fitness and food or
is what we can say about them going to
be determined by federal and state
policy state licensure is a protection
racket and that's all it is
Maur crypto is a weightlifting coach and
author of the book starting strength a
program distinct from CrossFit but which
shares certain commonalities like
promoting training with barbells and
encouraging movements that aren't
approved by establishment players in the
fitness industry the state legislature
that would adopt a statewide licensure
program for exercise is composed of
people who do not understand anything
about the squat ripto and CrossFit
trainers both promote what they call a
full squat which involves dipping below
parallel in contrast to the less
dramatic squat promoted by the American
College of Sports Medicine what do you
think they will say about our below
parallel squat it'll be in the document
as a standard of practice that squats
cannot be done below parallel I promise
you that you're removing the ability of
the purchaser of the product to
determine what he wants to get done in
his strength and conditioning program by
telling him essentially that he must buy
the services of a licensed guy who
cannot prescribe below parallel squats
because it's illegal them the
interaction or intersection of policy
and politics is a very problematic one
Holden McCray a sports medicine
professor at Pepperdine University and a
member of a CrossFit gym says that the
government's record on Fitness guidance
is spotty at best establishment fitness
began when Frank Shorter won the gold
medal in the Olympic marathon in Munich
in 1972 and the running boom took off
and then a big shift occurred in the mid
1990s in 1995 the Surgeon General issued
a report that shifted the
recommendations away from vigorous
activity towards low to moderate
intensity and D emphasized certain
fitness markers like strength agility
speed power and coordination putting
most of the focus on cardio respiratory
fitness the guidelines were adopted by
the American Heart Association the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention and the American College of
Sports Medicine the
government's national activity
guidelines published by Congress
recommend 150 minutes of moderate
physical activity a week moderate
physical activity that requirement
probably be satisfied by walking 30
minutes five times a week most people do
that accidentally it's very low standard
to hold a human being to doing yard work
or walking slowly around the block
that's not going to get you there I'm
sorry you actually have to work hard the
risk reduction for vigorous activity is
about two times greater compared to
moderate exercise it was an experiment
that was ran on the u.s. population with
very little evidence to support it
similar to what we had with the Dietary
Guidelines and I don't think there's
enough transparency with conflicts of
interest you know the involvement of big
soda for example recent work out of the
University of California San Francisco
has uncovered evidence that the sugar
lobby paid off researchers to downplay
the link between sugar and heart disease
with the very first paper that place
blame unsaturated fat having clear ties
to the sugar industry there's some
evidence that the same special interests
that used government and universities to
influence nutrition science for the past
several decades is employing similar
tactics in the fitness industry to
promote the message it's lack of
physical activity rather than sugar
consumption driving obesity most of the
focus in the popular media and in the
scientific press as though they're
eating too much eating too much eating
too much blaming fast-food blaming
sugary drinks and so on and there's
really virtually no compelling evidence
but that in fact is a cause that's a
video from the global energy balance
Network a group forced to disband after
its ties to coca-cola were revealed at
least one major group involved in the
occupational licensing fight has
received support from soda company
coca-cola did not reply to requests to
comment and the American College of
Sports Medicine declined to participate
in this story but a CSM's website does
say that it only advocates licensure for
trainers working with clients with
medical conditions that require minimal
to advanced clinical support a CSM's
newest venture exercises medicine is an
attempt to create a credentialing system
to have doc
prescribed fitness trainers to patients
and it was underwritten by the coca-cola
company even health organizations is
powerful and influential as the Centers
for Disease Control have received grants
from coca-cola so coca-cola has
partnered with the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention that fact alone
is sufficient to explain the degree of
the chronic disease prices that we're
facing in this country today
these are 501c3 proxies that are able to
keep their doors open by the
contributions from soda pop when you
think ACSM you better be thinking
coca-cola because that's that's what you
got the fields of nutrition and fitness
are littered with bad or incomplete
science that may take years or even
decades to sort out
and this is why ripto and Glassman are
skeptical the government can do anything
that makes the problem worse the
competitive marketplace and people who
consume strength conditioning
instruction is capable of sorting this
out am i happy with my training did I
get stronger did I get more fit these
should be the criteria that a
competitive marketplace provides for the
profession
[Music]